yeah chad is saying magnus would win
this for sure against the 1600 this is
not a true 1600 though this is just
somebody who hasn't played enough rated
games to have a proper rating i'm pretty
sure like
the first 60 moves that uh the tajiki
player has made in this game i mean she
is not a 1600
she is uh
i mean this is just a very very solid
game
yeah and that uh somebody in chat says
looks like she only had 18 total rated
games since 2019 so like the the
pandemic clearly
like a promising youngster basically has
like three years completely taken away
from their chess progress
this is what it looks like
yes and how nice that she gets now this
chance to play in the olympics yeah yeah
and also clearly uh
you know
her country knows how good she is
because you know she gets selected for
the team being rated 1600
you know it's a it's a reasonably large
country they you know they can find
chess players there it's a it's a
country which has a chess tradition so
if she gets selected for a national team
i'm pretty sure the
the
you know the the people selecting the
team are aware that this is probably not
operating